introduction to by informatics
introduction to bioinformatics is a
pilot program that will be run at MIT
University in Kolkata the program is
going to be dedicated to the
introduction of bioinformatics and we
will talk about the applications of data
science and biology biotechnology and
healthcare the program will take place
at Amity University Kolkata and will run
for three months
this will include 11 workshops that will
be followed by a team project the
program will be run by experienced
bioinformaticians that have experienced
both in academia and in industry
dr. Burton Chakraborty holds a PhD in
bioinformatics and dr. Mohan Mazumdar
holds a PhD in computational biology and
machine learning together they will be
working with faculty and students at MIT
University helping understand various
types of bioinformatics including
processing of next-generation sequencing
data application of various analysis
tools including machine learning tools
and interpretation this program will be
followed by a project where each faculty
member and a group of students will be
able to prepare and submit a poster or a
finished analysis of a project that they
have selected we will start off by
introducing the Onyx logic program the
Onyx logic program includes various
tools and resources that are provided in
the scope of this pilot that includes
online courses projects and datasets
that are already uploaded on the T bio
info analytical platform we'll also talk
about the expectations and schedule of
the training program including important
deadlines we will talk about Big Data
and bioinformatics
the topics that we will cover include
knowledge driven versus data-driven
discovery examples and various
applications in biotechnology
neuroscience agriculture cancer biology
immunology and various industries like
defense and healthcare and we'll talk
about the emergence of high throughput
experiments in life sciences how the
central dogma of molecular biology that
DNA code transcription of the genes and
translation into protein
can be measured in a qualitative and
quantitative way we'll talk about next
generation sequencing how we can use
this technology to detect DNA variance
and measure RNA expression then we will
transition to transcriptomics a section
dedicated to gene and Aiza form
expression in the context of this
section we will talk about the role of
pre-processing various mapping
techniques and quantification of genes
and isoforms in a sample we will then
talk about analysis of variance how we
can talk how we can use filtering noise
reduction in normalization techniques to
explore large multi-dimensional datasets
more accurately and summarize what we
have found using analysis of variance
how we can look at outliers and various
techniques so that we can detect groups
and trends in the data in
transcriptomics 3 we will talk about
more in-depth gene expression analysis
using correlation clustering and other
data mining techniques we will take a
look at analysis of genes and samples
based on those genes then we will talk a
little bit more about metagenomics the
microbiome is a hot topic and we will
talk about the reason and the
significance of metagenomics including
how next generation sequencing of 16s
hyper variable region helps us
understand the composition of the
microbiome and the taxonomy of bacteria
found in a specific sample we'll also
talk about the significance of the gut
microbiota for human health in
metagenomics 1 we will discuss the
various research areas and topics and
metagenomics how to practically build a
metagenomics analysis pipeline and
various methods that are used for
interpretation visualization and
analysis of results
in the introduction to machine learning
section we will talk about various
supervised and unsupervised machine
learning methods we will talk about
regression factors and features and we
will talk about various challenges
associated with different types of
methods in machine learning one we will
learn about decision trees discriminant
analysis and support vector machines we
will use feature selection and then talk
about how do we expand the number of
features that we want to include in our
analysis we will then talk about
dimensionality reduction and various
data visualization techniques finally we
will come to a stage where we were
transition from the theoretical learning
to the practical application of acquired
skills to an independent project here we
will talk about identification of
correct data sets for a bioinformatics
project various inputs in outputs
and how can that help us plan the team
project as we embark on this analysis
journey the significant time will be
allocated for team projects and
throughout we will meet and discuss the
selection and preparing the various
project components we will hold Q&A
sessions with students and faculty and
then transition to poster preparation
guidelines the hands-on sessions will be
conducted online and offline and will be
led by doctor per team Chakraborty and
Mohit Mazumdar throughout the program
each student will have access to our
online learning platform that contains
courses project examples and also helps
monitor progression so that each person
can look at their progress the various
courses that they have completed and the
points that they have accumulated in the
process of doing various tasks
associated with these courses even
though the topics we've covered might
sound technical and complicated you do
not need to worry we have a full
interactive online platform that anyone
with even the most basic can
skills can use that means that complex
bioinformatics methods running
computationally intensive pipelines and
visualization of results can all be done
in a simple point-and-click interface
for those that have followed the program
and have completed the necessary
materials a certificate of participation
will be offered we hope that you will
join us for this exciting course in
introduction to bioinformatics we are
excited to work with aiming to
university Kolkata to introduce
bioinformatics to a wide range of
students and faculty and see how
together we can develop impactful
projects that will help understand the
applications of bioinformatics to
various domains including healthcare
biotechnology biochemistry and their
applications in agriculture neuroscience
oncology and immunology
you